ladies and gentlemen we got breaking
news from project veritas
new york times national security
reporter says the january 6 media
coverage over the top and the fbi was
involved
nyt national security correspondent
matthew rosenberg contradicts his own
january 6 reporting quote there were a
ton of fbi informants amongst the people
who attacked the capital quote it was
like me and two other colleagues who
were there outside and we were just
having fun i know i'm supposed to be
traumatized but like all these
colleagues who were in the capital
building are like omg was so scary i'm
like eff off i'm like come on it's not
the kind of place i can call someone i
can tell someone to man up but i kind of
want to be like dude come on you are not
in any danger these effing little dweebs
who keep
going on about their trauma shut the f
up they're effing [ __ ]
they were making too big a deal they
were making this an organized thing that
wasn't
will i stand by those comments
absolutely except when james o'keefe
confronted
i i don't know if it was this guy who
did he confront this guy on the street
or another uh another journalist he
confronted him uh they wouldn't comment
on any of this stuff i don't think this
was this one
he just posted let me where's my do they
because usually when they do one of
these they confront the people in the
video did they do that in this video i
haven't seen it yet i think i want i
wanna i wanna fact check make sure in
real time that i'm right because i just
followed the sierra james o'keefe and uh
no okay so right i was right it was
someone else right mark mazzetti
was the guy that got confronted by james
o'keefe over uh i believe this story so
you have this guy this is this is
matthew uh national security adviser
matthew rosenberg who's saying these
things and a different new york times
reporter was being was being um
questioned or challenged over it so
the point of this story i'll tell you
first and foremost
the media these journalists they believe
exactly what we've been saying that it
was bad but come on you're traumatized
it wasn't that bad that there were fbi
informants involved behind the scenes
they all know it publicly they won't say
it they won't report it i'm wondering
why anyone should care at this point if
the new york times comes out and says
there's no evidence there's the fbi
involved is anyone going to listen do
you care if other people who are dumb as
a box of rocks listen what are you gonna
do you can't convince them there's dumb
as a box of rocks
well it's funny that he is reporting uh
ostensibly on the side of the media
there's a new york time reporter he's
upholding the narrative and then behind
closed doors he's saying this is pretty
much nonsense i'm over the narrative it
just goes to show that what the
polling has said is valid which is that
more americans want to see the 2020
riots investigated than want to see
january 6th investigated it's something
like less than half of americans it's
it's
40 something percent 46 percent uh think
that the january 6 committee is good and
they want the investigation to continue
and two-thirds of voters want congress
to investigate the 2020 riot so people i
mean the narrative is falling apart even
among the people who are supposed to be
forwarding it correct
there are also two reasons why you
should care about about what about that
and the first reason is you know all the
people all the non-violent defendants
from j6 that are still in jail without
lawyers without trials they're being
hunt they were hunted down by the doj
and the fbi these people for trespassing
charges and locked them away the second
reason you should care is because this
january 6 committee in congress is
targeting republicans that had nothing
to do with january 6 they had nothing to
do with the riot at the capitol they are
simply political opponents of people on
the committee right one of those people
is my boss alex brujiwicz who all he did
was organize several peaceful protests
against the election he did not go into
the capital on january 6 he was not
involved but he got a subpoena and had
to testify today another example is uh
andrew serabian and arthur schwartz who
are two more gop strategists they got a
subpoena and they weren't even there or
working for trump on january 6 they're
simply friends with donald trump jr and
running a super pac that's opposing liz
cheney so why why why why aren't they
refusing
well they are well they are well you
know because you can be held in contempt
like you can you can have criminals well
yeah you can have criminal charges filed
against you but there there's the the
charges i think bannon got like a
misdemeanor you know i don't know yeah i
don't i don't know what's gonna happen
but i'm wondering why so many people are
just like okay
alex jones pleaded the fifth well yeah
on the legal well it's different on the
legal side like when we just talk about
it you know it seems like it'd be easy
to do that but these people are putting
the full force of government on on a lot
of these innocent people that didn't do
anything wrong i think republicans are
pathetic i was going to swear
but i try not to
but um overwhelmingly pathetic
yeah well whenever you have republican
leadership complaining about how the far
left has taken this country too far in
that direction you have to ask why did
you let them right well there's just so
many people who are like
you know a good example is the don't say
gay bill
we'll get into in a minute i don't want
to i don't want to derail into that i
just want to highlight how even
conservative outlets are referring it to
it by that instead of calling it the
actual title of the bill or just like
hr1557 or whatever
they're and they're going along with it
i'm just like that that's why i like the
other day we mentioned christina
paschall the spokesperson for desantis
when she called the anti-grooming bill
and basically called the democrats
groomers i'm like no that's what i call
spine or when ron desantis walked up to
those kids and was like you don't got to
wear those if you don't want to
you know take please take them off and
he i think he said later that he didn't
want people to think he made them do it
she's like i don't care if you wear it
just you know i'm not making you do it
so too often
we have uh people who are just like i'll
just you know i'll do what i'm told and
i'll go along with their abuse of power
you get donald trump what what what do
the republicans do when uh the first two
years of donald trump's presidency a
whole hot nothing yeah
or or went i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry for the president i'm so sorry
that my party acts this way they had
they had they had congress
and they gave it up
yeah they're not going to do anything
now they're going to just keep
collecting a paycheck sorry go on no
it's just they need term limits this is
ridiculous as a point of clarification
eric with project veritas is telling me
that they did confront rosen oh they did
yeah that's coming out uh in the future
all right yeah i'm just saying the video
they posted over is of mark mazzetti
right right
because every time they do one of these
they always confront the person about
what they said and usually they just run
away from them so here's a journalist
saying it wasn't organized like outright
saying it wasn't organized
that's interesting reporter you know
we've got to trust nyt okay yeah yeah
yeah behind closed doors they tell you
one thing dude our institutions are
controlled by evil despicable people and
there's no real political opposition the
republican party for the most part is
the no way don't party just do it in a
couple weeks from now no wait don't
we're losing we're being beaten down
every policy we push forward is a half
measure and the democrats are getting
what they want
better not push too hard you don't
understand they're like they're like
here's the art of the deal you start
with the compromise
and then they'll give you what you
really want no no no sheamus they're
saying here's the art of the deal you
start with the compromise and then you
give in to their demands exactly you
just give them everything they want
i mean the gun issue is there and then
they like you then they're then they're
your friend and they won't call you
racist anymore how many republicans have
come out and been like abolish gun gun
law restrictions none yeah i mean i i
it's not really fair i think margaret
taylor green and lauren very small
handful but those are radicals tim yeah
well it's hilarious i've said this on
the show before but whenever a
republican actually tries to reverse
left-wing policy rather than simply
upholding the status quo or arguing that
our rights should be intruded upon more
slowly they're referred to as a radical
even though the whole point of their
position is for them to reverse that
which the left is put in place
i'm waiting i'm waiting you guys keep
talking i'm waiting for source
confirmation on some some breaking facts
i'm thinking about the history of
leadership governments and stuff most of
them i think have been pretty bad over
the years like if you take a thousand
years you probably got like 960 years of
trash leadership and then you get these
great these people that are so good
because they're just actually good and
then they call them the great or
something like that they give them these
titles because they were actually
intelligent people somehow they got into
power that didn't get themselves killed
uh it's not common throughout history
it's very rare to see a fantastic leader
and a good governance you know hammurabi
did it that was like not eight thousand
years ago or something stupid yeah i i
just want to say i i kind of don't
understand how this show exists because
we push back on each other no no i mean
like you've got the new york times
outright lying about all the stuff
you've got the government coming and
rounding people up into solidarity
confinement and somehow we're able to
criticize them very heavily and keep
talking about this and showing like
veritas and and pushing back on it
i'm just like
after everything we've seen after every
media organization has lied about almost
every single story how does it show like
this i think it's because don't hold
your breath buddy
i mean i think i think the success of
this show kind of derives from that when
people where people are waking up to the
fact that all these people do is lie and
all they are are tools for the large
corporations and the establishment in
this country and shows like this aren't
and that's what
what i mean is why hasn't youtube taken
why are we alive because the people in
charge are are not they're they're being
coerced by the military industrial
complex no one wants freedom of speech
gone
like the people that are really in
charge of google don't they're not evil
they're just being coerced by the staff
by this established force i would like
if they were truly evil they would have
shut it down a long time ago
i mean that that may be true
but i i kind of i think you're rolling
around here i want on this one i don't
think you need to censor people i think
you just need to assassinate their
character obviously at some point they
do want to censor we've seen them do it
before people have been deleted from
youtube but why take down tim's show
when all you have to do is say tim pool
is a far-right extreme he doesn't want
anyone who repeats what he says is a
bigot but that doesn't work at some
point it doesn't you're correct and i
think that's when they do start taking
people down but
the average person is still too afraid
to talk about these things at their
place of work or somewhere when they
aren't sure that they're surrounded by
like-minded individuals unfortunately i
am kind of curious how long hopefully
you have on youtube and i'm glad we put
our stuff on other sites and i'm glad
that we have the website i would like to
mention as well i've got some uh just an
update from veritas themselves
that their next installment is
discussing new york times sources the
nsa and the cia and that they do
confront this individual so this should
be interesting but um i think people at
google are evil i think people at
twitter are evil i think there's a
combination of evil and the banality of
evil and i do know it comes up a lot but
it is a good reference point the the joe
rogan twitter episode that i did where i
think you need only look at
when i was talking with jack and said
what is your reasoning for the
misgendering policy and they said oh
because you know certain people have a
higher propensity towards suicide and i
said what about people with body
dysmorphia or whatever it's called you
know it's called general body
dysmorphia something like that people
who want to like cut off their own hands
or something oh yeah and they didn't
have an answer to that yeah or when i
said if conservatives think your
misgendering policy is inverted why do
you side with only one half of the
country instead of yeah so clearly
they have a worldview completely
detached from yours they're willing to
silence and do whatever they want
because in their world view it's what we
were talking about yesterday they're the
within
the two parent factions of the culture
war there are those who believe in
inalienable rights whether you're
religious or not there are people who
believe there exists something outside
of you and people other people have
equal right to life liberty and
happiness and then you have the woke
cultists who believe that power is
derived by force and they can take
whatever they want
so that's like
you know overarching narratives here we
here are like honest because well you
should decide for yourself in your life
because i respect you and your your life
and you do what you want the other side
believes that power should be seized and
you seize power by lying and lying to
people and manipulating them well as
jack dorsey said tim if conservatives
are allowed to express their views on
twitter trans people aren't safe to
express theirs so censorship is actually
promoting free speech did he actually
say that that's not exactly how he put
it but that's what he i mean that's what
he said his whole argument was that
transgender people are not in a safe
space where they can speak freely unless
those who would quote-unquote misgender
them are unable to do so let's talk
about it's not a misrepresentation of
this argument that's what i mean that's
what he was saying and
oh sorry no no just to make another
point about that i think you know it
goes back to the fact that republicans
controlled the presidency and both
chambers of commerce or commerce
congress for two years and didn't do
anything about big tech censorship
there's there
there are laws that can be changed that
can prevent these big tech companies
from censoring people and republicans
just didn't do it
the good news is i think a lot of the
gop start a lot of gop politicians and a
lot of are starting to wake up and get
it and understand that hey
we can make reforms to section 230 we
can make reforms to these laws that can
that can you know stop big tech from
censoring people and we'll see if it
happens
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there